greetings everyone and welcome my name
is Rob Sanders from simply learned in
today we're gonna talk about content
marketing strategy so buckle up and
let's get right to it and we're gonna
get right into some of the best
practices some tips some methodologies
some things you should be doing with
content marketing so right out of the
gate let's start talking about knowing
your audience
okay so content is all about writing for
a particular audience so it's just like
speaking except when we're speaking of
somebody we're speaking directly to them
content is very similar and so we have
to be able to know our audience ahead of
time so what you can do is collect
demographics of your target audience
based on who's coming to your website so
you can get that data in Google
Analytics under audience email
subscribers I mean who is subscribing to
your emails who do you already have in
your email database and you can look at
social media I mean you look at Facebook
you can look at the people who are
already connected to you okay these are
just some three three of many examples
you could be doing to gather data on
your audience okay you have to know who
your audience is before you start
writing you know for a successful
content marketing strategy you really
just need to know your audience and
basically you're gonna segment them
based on their interests so that content
is gonna be catered to that audience
okay so if it's a lines that likes a
specific you know product that you offer
or feature that's part of that product
that you offer then that's the segment
you're gonna be writing about so you
need to collect your data on your
audience ahead of time then you're gonna
segment that audience okay so you're not
gonna write content for everyone because
the shoe doesn't necessarily fit for
everyone
okay the shoe has to fit for specific
foot and in this case we're talking
about an
we need to speed up a segment our
audience out and you could certainly
segment them out by age by gender by
education level by income by interest I
mean these are just some of the examples
again it could be new returning or Noori
users versus returning users it could be
users who are purchased from you in the
past versus users who haven't purchased
from you in the past it could certainly
be an age range it could be even going
further on interest level or combination
thereof okay so for example you can get
that demographic information using
Google Analytics just got to go in
analytics under audience under
demographics you're gonna see age and
its age is broken out by age range and
they're gonna see gender so you're gonna
see a breakdown of gender and use that
to your Vantage so if you're going to
you know write some content and you know
99% of your traffic is female over the
age of 18 to 24 then you know that
contents make catered accordingly so you
could certainly go to Facebook page
insights and get some really good
demographic data there cuz Facebook is
all about demographics okay so you could
see exactly you know how many fans you
have broken out by men versus women and
you can see again same thing as Google
Analytics you can see an age range break
out you could use Twitter analytics I
mean Twitter hash share some really good
insights into education level so you
know if you're dealing with you know
highly sophisticated people who have
master's degrees or even higher or let's
just say even on LinkedIn you know that
majority of the people you're trying to
target our C level meaning CEOs or CFOs
or CMOS
you know chief marketing officers or
chief executive officers then you're
going to cater your message a little bit
different than say mid-range
managers or you know even high range
managers or even VP's so use your
audience information you collect on
these various platforms to your
advantage
okay so let's jump into number two we
want to create high quality content now
I know this sounds like a given but and
I say but heavily not a high quality
content out there on the Internet so
separate yourself first and foremost
always always always create high quality
content it's gonna result in a lot of
things are gonna benefit you you know
one you're gonna come across as you know
somebody who knows what they're talking
about and that's gonna help increase
your brand awareness okay when you
increase your brand awareness people
know about you so it's likely going to
increase traffic to your website or if
you're on social media you know if you
produce good high quality content people
are going to share that content okay so
from an SEO perspective it can improve
website ranking meaning if you have good
quality content you know and it's really
focused in on a specific topic or a
certain set of core words keywords then
you're gonna wring improves website
dwell time meaning hey you got good
content people are gonna hang around to
see what else you have to offer okay so
it's no secret that you know good
content you usually leads to you know
quality engagement and then certainly
last but not least you can gain a lot of
leads here meaning hey somebody likes
what you have to say whether that's a
video or blog post or infographic you
know people are gonna become more
interest and more engaged spend more
time and that's all going to funnel
through to somebody taking that next
step in the funnel and becoming more
interesting in your service or even
purchasing one of your products so
creating high quality content involves
brainstorming topics and terms you know
you've got to do the upfront work due
diligence is at work here so brainstorm
some topics use a keyword research tool
to gather results so if you have a topic
you know one of the benefits of quality
content
is rankings go to Google's keyword
planner
I understand how much quality and and
understand how much competition each
keyword has or understand how much
volume each keyword has that's what's
available in Google's keyword planner or
any really any keyword planning tool you
always want to create original content
okay so you don't want to plagiarize or
take somebody else's content and then
you want to support that content with
compelling headlines so if you have a
piece of content you got to get
somebody's attention write a nice
headline that's gonna grab their
attention okay so give valuable content
to readers and add resources from
well-known sites so if you you do borrow
say a data point from another source
then you know cite that source you also
want to create engaging in
thought-provoking content get somebody
to think I mean people are gonna read
your content because they not they don't
know the subject matter their interests
in this subject matter and they want to
be able to spend the time taking
something away from that content follow
a logical structure and use relevant
images I can't stress this one enough
you know just throw things on a webpage
you know put some structure to it you
have to break it out if you feel like
you have too much content there's no
harm and breaking it into part 1 versus
part to get people tease them a bit get
them to come back and read part 2 can
use different content forms okay
somebody's interested maybe you want to
capture some data you know prefer short
paragraphs to make the content readable
remember if you're talking to c-level
folks you know maybe you don't have to
dummy down the content so to speak but
if you're dealing with you know folks or
people that right out of high school or
still in high school then adjust your
content in format and paragraphs
accordingly and then update the content
as well just because you publish it
doesn't mean that it's done I mean we're
talking about a webpage we're talking
about something that is actively
changing or can change the medium that
is dynamic okay so if a data points
change go back in and update that data
point
and then let people know about it
because they may want to come back and
and you know check it in to see how much
that data points changed so these are
all you know good takeaways for creating
high quality content and some other
things that you should be aware of you
know grammatical mistakes you know you
need to avoid those there's no reason
for grammatical mistakes today's
technology doesn't allow for it and hey
listen we all have friends we have
colleagues my desk is sitting next to a
colleague who's more than happy to read
something before it gets published so
take advantage of the resources you have
available no reason for because if you
have a grammatical mistake you just lost
a lot of credibility you know don't be
afraid to add a clear call-to-action at
the end of your content if somebody is
interested in reading it they're
probably going to be interested in
taking the next step whatever that next
step is ok so creating content that
fulfills viewers requirements meaning
somebody's searching for something and
your content shows up in the search
results then they're actively looking
for you what are you offering them is it
fulfilling their requirements you don't
be afraid to use examples throughout
your content in fact work in or
integrate some case studies in there
show clear examples to stress your
points and then just don't put words on
a webpage you know so break up that
content with an image that's gonna be
visually appealing okay and you can add
images from public domain sites meaning
stock imagery if that's what's going to
help create visually appealing content
and then give more information to your
audience and we say prefer to give more
information meaning hey going back to
the content I was saying about breaking
it up organizing it if you have more
information
you don't withhold it have them come
back and read a secondary blog post or
secondary piece that supports the
original now we want to move from high
quality content to running a B test
maybe test so important why because with
a B split testing you can increase your
conversion
okay so four elements to test and your
content marketing strategy so if you
have content say a blog and you're
testing that blog you test out the
images test out the forms do you have a
long form or short form you know test
out the content length you can have a
variation that is a lot shorter than the
original does that increase or decrease
bounce rates play around with call to
actions you know call to actions do
matter you know do you want to use a
softer call-to-action a softer tone or
do you want to use something very direct
and strong you know test call to actions
to see what's gonna get people to move
closer through the closer to purchasing
them through that funnel so a/b testing
to me is something that should be
naturally done with Google optimized
it's free so with images you know you
could test a lot of different variations
of images anything from people to you
know outlandish image rage is just
something very stock and neutral but
just make sure that those images are
relevant to the post you know test the
length of that content you know again if
you know that your average time on page
is very low you know don't write
something very long write something that
you think is gonna stick with that time
on page but on your a/b test creates
something maybe a little longer if it's
engaging enough maybe somebody's gonna
stay a little bit longer on the page so
you know create a variation that's gonna
play with that length okay so use
analytics to your advantage to figure
out as a baseline what amount of content
is getting people to stay on the page
then see if you could push the envelope
one way or the other
okay improving the page with sign up
forms really what you want to do is
create a user-friendly experience so
when you have signup forms and don't
make them non-intuitive don't make them
difficult you know link maybe up to
Facebook or Google so if they're
creating an account they can create an
account via Google or Facebook or you
know don't put too many forms on the
page and then on those CTAs as I
mentioned play around with the tone you
can also play around the color I mean I
test color all the time believe my color
does matter don't use red
use green people react to different
colors but again you have cultural
variances as well so you got to take
that into account if you're in the
Middle East or the Far East Asia you
know color schemes and what you say
matters and it changes versus say you
know Europe or the West okay so keep
that in mind when you're making changes
in color or tone or placement and things
of that nature so you want to conduct a
competitor analysis so we're talking
about creating high quality content
testing that content you know
brainstorming some topics you know
looking at your audience you're doing
all this work you might a little take
the next step and figure out what it is
your competitors are doing so you can
opt for competitive analysis by
identifying your competitors top
performing content for specific topics
okay and so really what we're trying to
do here is improve our conversion rates
so what are your competitors doing what
are their baselines we can maybe up that
Annie I mean that data is also available
in Google Analytics so you can look at
benchmarking reports in Google Analytics
to get some form or fashion
you can also go to Facebook and look at
your competitors Facebook pages and see
what's perform and in terms of
engagement but what you want to do is
find out your strongest competitors by
using search engines or check which
websites are competing with you and
again that could include Facebook as
well or maybe even LinkedIn so you go
with the search engine route you can
always type in that coveted keyword that
you want to be found for see who's
ranking ahead of you and you can see the
metadata meaning the title tag in the
meta description you can actually see
hey what are these guys writing that's
getting them recognized in the search
engine rankings so you can certainly if
you go to search engine route you could
certainly leverage an SEO platform like
search SEM rush or Moz or something like
that that's going to allow you to get
some good insight on competitor
information so keep in mind there are
SEO platforms that will give you
information
your competitors and that's what these
SEO platforms are good for so number
five moving on choose a suitable content
format so now we've done all this
homework we know what we want to say we
know who we want to say it to we're
ready to do some testing but we need to
find a format because it's not always
about a web page per se meaning content
on a web page there's not always about a
blog post with content in that blog post
okay we need to decide the type of
content that's going to fit what we're
trying to say so again you can go the
traditional route with just posting a
blog post there nothing wrong with that
because with the blog post you can
incorporate video and imagery you can
also go more harder route when I say
harder more a say official route with an
e-book or case study something that a
user is going to be able to take away
with maybe download something more
official something more in-depth
something with a harder stamp on it so
that that shows individuals that you've
taken the time you've done this
homework you've done this research
you've done some really in-depth
analysis and now the proper format for
that is not blog post it's an e-book now
if you're in a talking like I am then
you could certainly do a podcast and
podcasts are always popular depending on
the topic so you got to be aware of the
topic now videos are always always a
good option you've got the likes of
video and video and YouTube and some
other you know video platforms out there
that allow you the ability to get found
very quickly especially with the likes
of YouTube you know people use YouTube
before they go on to purchasing a
product so think about that so if you're
trying to get somebody if we're trying
to sway an audience to move from being a
brand awareness and a loyal you know
customer to taking the next step okay to
purchasing more or purchasing for the
first time and some videos kind of help
convey that now if you're trying to
convey a lot of different points then an
infographic might be your best off
instead I'm having to write out all
those points you try using an
infographic to convey those points
visually now again with blog posts it
should have valuable content that can be
shared by your website visitors on
socials so that's the key make sure you
have those shareable social icons now
with ebooks it should have longer an
in-depth content so and it shouldn't be
published frequently so maybe if this is
something you're doing annually then
ebook could be the format with a case
study what you should have a customer
story that succeeded and you solving
that customers problem so the case study
is always there for you know somebody to
get an idea of what you're all about
infographic is just visualizing data in
a more organized way in a more visual
way
so somebody understands what you're
trying to convey now with that podcast
again suppose your audience doesn't have
an interest in reading again it could be
a certain age certain gender a certain
culture
hey everybody absorbs information
differently so think about it ask
yourself is a podcast the best way to
communicate to my target audience and
then videos are highly engaging they're
also shareable on blog posts and pretty
much most if not all social media
platforms so once you've done that once
you choose the proper format you want to
choose a content management system
that's going to work for you so you want
to be able to choose something where you
can plan appropriately produce manage
publish and measure results all in one
place there plenty of content management
systems out there that will help you do
all of those things ok so some examples
are WordPress
HubSpot binder I mean we can list
hundreds if you're into blogging you
know WordPress is the way to go if
you're into building and landing pages
that you want to you know share you know
HUD spot could be the way to go okay
there are lots of available options out
there so moving on number seven target
your audience using email
okay so what are we talking about well
we all know what emails are emails help
us to communicate directly with our
target audience and convert them to
leads so email is a good way to follow
up with your audience so if you've done
a podcast follow up with an email you
maybe get them to you know fill out a
survey via email based on that podcast
or if you create a podcast about some
data that you talked about in that
podcast follow up that with with them
via email with an infographic perhaps
okay built into the email
okay there's lots of ways that all these
formats can complement themselves via
email okay you can certainly take a blog
post and package it into an email and
have a link pointing back to the blog
post maybe as a teaser or if you're
doing a series a series of blog posts
you know you could tease that in an
email so an email is a good way to
you'll follow up with your target
audience indirectly or directly when we
say indirectly you know you can collect
emails and send out those emails with
you know certain information or what you
should be doing is targeting and
segmenting your emails just like you are
your content so if you're producing
content for certain audience then make
sure that particular audience gets that
same email now some of the email content
that you could share with your target
audience our newsletters okay seasonal
emails promotional emails automated
messaging and what we mean by automated
messaging hey if somebody just purchased
from you
samih thank you email maybe follow up a
couple days later with another email
with a survey or what you could do is if
you know who your loyal customers are
you know target them with a promotional
email so there's lots of ways to slice
and dice content via email okay just
make sure you know your target audience
is there's lots of things you can do an
email again you can compliment lots of
different formats within email as I
mentioned before with a podcast or a
blog post so keep all that in mind email
is a good way to communicate with your
audience
okay the last point we want to make here
is use
native ads okay so we talk about native
ads it's one of the smartest ways to
connect your audience with your brand so
for example this is a native ad on
BuzzFeed it's about 15 bands that
probably wouldn't exist without Led
Zeppelin okay so for you folks out there
they don't know who Led Zeppelin is a
rock group from the 70s late 60s 70s
okay disbanded in 80 81 82 early 80s
okay but you know people grow up like
myself listening to Led Zeppelin okay so
you can see the headline here 50 mins
that probably won't exist with the
outlet Zeppelin you know I'm interested
who those bands might be even if you
don't know who Led Zeppelin is okay you
might be inquisitive to say okay who is
this Led Zeppelin group and what are
these 15 bands the key here is not to
say the headline or Led Zeppelin per se
but it's a native ad and it's sitting
next to content talking about music okay
so according to Forbes online audiences
are 25% more likely to look at a native
ad than add a banner and so that native
ad in this case we're talking about
music needs to be sitting or accompanied
alongside content talking about in this
case music you know would help if it was
rock music music in general might get
enough to get peak people's interest
okay so if you're gonna create content
you know align that content with
something that's you know naturally
going to fit and that's why we call them
native ads because they're native to the
content that they're associated with so
finally after all that said and done
when all you've done is create good
content follow up the emails targeting
your audience and associated that
content with you know content natively
then you can always measure your content
performance so there's my favorite part
of it all you go in analytics go on a
Facebook Insights you know you want to
go in and check out how that constants
performing and you want to do that
because you want to be able to see
what's performing what's not performing
the key here is associating the content
with KPIs
that's really the key so measuring the
right metrics can help you understand
whether your content is engaging or not
so again measuring the right metrics
okay so when we're talking about a video
you're not necessary gonna look at page
views you're gonna look at video views
so you know some of these basic metrics
of users and sessions of pages bounce
rate you know dwell time that's all
great but you just need to make sure
that you're aligning the right metric
with the right asset so for example if
you have a case study and rebook you
want to make sure that you're measuring
how many downloads the e-book or the
case study received again with the video
you want to measure video views now if
you're packaging up emails and sending
them out to your target audience you
want to make sure you look at open rates
and click rates okay so a lot of things
you can be looking at so make sure you
choose the right metrics is there's
hundreds and hundreds of metrics to
choose from so just be aware all the
different metrics that are available you
know if you're in it for search okay how
much traffic getting from search where
are you ranking so a lot of things you
need to think about so think about the
content that you're producing and think
about how you want to be able to measure
that content so let's go back over our
checklist here so what you could do is
create an editorial calendar in fact I
would highly suggest you create an
editorial calendar in order to keep
track of all the content you've done
over a period of time are you making
your content worth reading that means
are you checking the results of that
content what we just went over measuring
the content is it worth reading have a
column set up in that editorial calendar
you know performing or not performing if
it's not performing don't do it again
okay curate your content okay you always
want to you know make sure reusing or
using or adding to the content
that you've created guest post on
influential blogger websites you want to
add statistics numbers and quotes to
your content make it engaging make it
look like you've done your homework
you could share all your content not
just on social media but you know
platforms like SlideShare now you can
share it on all social media platforms
I'd highly recommend it and again you
can even repurpose it as a blog post so
if it's a podcast and you know you can
recite that podcast in the form of a
blog okay so get some testimonials that
support some of your content again
create a podcast you can send on an
email with a survey or trying to solicit
some testimonials or if you post
something on Facebook you know leverage
the feedback you get from Facebook in
the form of a testimonial okay and then
you want to promote your blog post for
maximum success and a lot of that means
SEO so make sure you do your due
diligence and get the right keywords in
that blog post okay so you can create
personas for different user audiences
okay so remember it's all about tone
okay so if you're gonna create a blog
post make sure your tone is aligned with
that right audience whether that be
young middle-aged or older are you
choosing the right type of content okay
you'll know based on the results okay
you want to add h1 and h2 tags on your
web pages why because when we're talking
about content we're talking about
organizing the content in h1 and h2 s
help you organize the content
appropriately customize the metadata
metadata is title tag and meta tag
descriptions and even alt tags okay all
of that is for search so you want your
content to show up and search whether
that's video infographic or blog post
all of it can be shown in search results
so make sure you write a good title and
make sure you write a good meta
description because that's what people
are going to see when they search so you
want to create a detailed summary and
title and again that goes along with the
title tag a meta description and then
you want to make it easy for the
audience to ask questions and
on your blog so don't be afraid like I'm
gonna do right now in this video is if
I'm missing anything from this checklist
feel free to comment
hey I've written my fair share content
but I could be talking to an audience
that is just as qualified as I am and
they may have some tips so feel free to
comment underneath this video now don't
be afraid to ask just like I just did
people are always willing to provide
constructive feedback so don't be afraid
to ask for it and make it easy so to me
every blog post needs to have some form
of a comment box because blog posts are
out there to solicit engagement now
let's recap everything we talked about
because we'd certainly covered a lot and
there's a lot to cover when it comes to
content marketing so 1 know your
audience
again you can lean on google analytics
you know demographic data whether it be
age or gender you could do the same with
Facebook and Twitter and LinkedIn you
know every platform has some data you
could take away create high-quality
content when I mean high quality content
sprain storm some topics has it already
been written to death about or is this
unique you know don't write something
your competitors are writing ok don't
copy what your competitors have written
organize your content support it with
good imagery all of these are tips to
creating high quality content ok when
you create that content think about
running some a/b test you know run some
variations and switch out the image
switch out the call-to-action see what's
going to get people to react and engage
with the content conduct competitor
analysis so lean on the Facebook's of
the world to see what your competitors
are posting and see what's engaging for
them ok you can also lean on these SEO
platforms like SEM rush and Moz all you
got to do is plug in a domain and
they're gonna give you some information
about where particular competitor ranks
for keyword or how many backlinks and
what websites are linking to them so all
that's available in these SEO platforms
ok so you want to choose a suitable
content format we listed a few
from ebooks to case studies to podcasts
to infographics to blog post the videos
it's up to you what you think is best
for your audience just keep in mind you
need to be able to measure it and so
that's the important thing if it doesn't
work the first time out then you might
want to consider changing out the
content format choose a content
management system you know plenty out
there WordPress is a good one if you're
going to be a blogger ok blogging allows
you to you know post optimize that blog
post you know you could have the ability
to share that blog post across social
platforms and you can also have that
blog post show up in search engine
results so you can't do any of that
without a good content management system
so you want to target your audience
using emails ok so email is a good way
to again further communicate with that
particular segmented audience and again
you could use it to send out promotional
emails to loyal followers or you can use
systematic emails to send an email a
thank you most somebody purchases and
then another follow-up email and again
you can repurpose some of the content
you've done and another format in the
form of an email so you know if you
created a video you know put that video
in the form of an email sent out to your
audience to make sure they're not
missing out on that video you just
created so lots of ways to use email
take advantage of email it's your ally
here ok use native ads ok don't be
afraid to put that content and pair it
with some other content on another
website it's been proven people are
going to engage in an ad that they see
based on the content they're currently
reading because the ad if it's native
it's going to be similar in nature to
the content they're currently engaged in
and then measure your content
performance I can't say this enough make
sure you're leveraging Google Analytics
ok with Google Analytics or Facebook
Insights or Twitter or LinkedIn or any
other platform you're running on they're
going to have
on what you've posted so take advantage
of it
line your KPI so if it's an e-book or
case study don't measure just traffic
measure how many people actually
downloading them okay if it's a video
you how many people like the video how
many people are commenting how many
people are sharing the video how many
people are subscribing to your playlist
based on that video content okay so
these are all things you can measure
okay so every platform from WordPress to
YouTube to reddit has some form of
analytics associated with it
a lot of information on content
marketing if you have any questions or
comments feel free to post right
underneath this video thanks for paying
attention I appreciate it if you need
more information please visit us at
simply learn com
thank you hi there
if you liked this video subscribe to the
simple learn YouTube channel and click
here to watch similar videos Dinard up
and get certified click here